you
[Music]
okay today's my great pleasure to
introduce Kevin buzzers he's a professor
of pure mathematics at Imperial College
he received the Whitehead Award for his
distinguished work in number theory in
2002 he also received the senior berrak
Awards in 2008 he's a number theorist
he's also interested in formalizing
mathematics AI for math and how
technology can improve math education
Kevin's extremely popular with his
students I met him and many of the
unless she had flock as a last remark as
many of you know Danielson is starting
the International method mathematical
Olympiads grand challenge where the goal
should get a gold medal in this
challenging and prestigious competition
few weeks ago Madame found out that
Kevin is a master puzzle solver he got a
perfect score when he was a students a
gold medal and today Daniel and I had
the pleasure to see him in action
solving some of these puzzles and it was
human ingenuity at its best and how many
magical steps are needed for solving
them the problems in this competition
the competition has six mathematical
puzzles all the top students participate
and many of them tales of only or true
of these problems if you think boy's
heart is a finite section in space in
this competition is an infinite section
space and with many magical moves that
demonstrate human ingenuity today
Kevin's going to talk about the future
of mathematics and how technology is
affecting it thank you thank you for the
invitation thank you there for the
introduction so as he says I'm a
professor of pure mathematics Imperial
College sighs and I'm an algebraic
number theory so I have no background in
computing at all I'm used computers
completely informally I've written
Python code to solve games on my phone
and things like this but no programming
background at all I know I used computer
algebra packages in particular I've used
sage written by
William Stein you say with us to do
calculations to do computation you know
I want to check a million examples of
something but really I'm interested in
theorem proving and there's theorem
proving software nowadays and I work in
a regular math department and no one in
my math department has heard of this
theorem proving software it's even has
theorem in the title some of his stuff
this is it is supposed to be this is
supposed to be for mathematicians but no
mathematicians use it so in some sense
the most surprising part of the slide is
that a mathematician actually started to
engage with this software and yeah and
all my colleagues thought I was mad at
so I started I started goofing around
with the lien theorem prover which which
is that this is a software that
Microsoft Nena but Lee I was written the
Microsoft Research is written and the
reason I did it I'll get to it but the
reason I did it was because not for my
research but because I was interested
because I was given an introduction to
proof course to teach I was told to
teach the basic introduction to prove
course and I started thinking about what
a proof was and and these computer
theorem provers you have an extremely
precise definition of what a proof is so
that was how I got interested because of
an educational yeah because reasons and
then I it slowly dawned on me what this
software can do and now and now I'll
absolutely convinced that that that this
software has an integral part to play in
the future of mathematics so many of my
peers don't think this yet but many of
my peers don't I I think it's inevitable
that's the point and I think it's only a
matter of time before mathematicians
start waking up and smelling the coffee
so which there's many theorem provers
and I'm not saying this because I'm here
I might be I might be here because I
believe this might be more likely sir
more likely to be true
but I about so I started using lean two
years ago but six months ago I thought I
should probably try and look at all the
software available and I looked at all
the software available just with this
one goal in mind of doing all of
mathematics somehow learning attempting
to attempting to do all of pure
mathematics and I'm absolutely convinced
that if you want to do all of pure
mathematics then then Microsoft is
currently the winner I think hands down
I mean that might not be true forever
but I think the lean you know this is
some technical issue to do with what
kind of type theory it's using and how
one can use it but at the minute I think
you're sitting on the goldmine and but
I'm not you know in fight in 10 years
time things might be very different so
I'm not saying lean is going to solve
all the problems but tool such as lean
are gonna going to change the way
mathematics works and probably quite
soon right in the maybe in the near
future they're gonna be helping us how
do you do sir as a mathematician I I
have a technical you know I'm doing my
research I have some technical question
about very very complicated objects you
can't Google for the answer to that
question yet Google is a useless so I
mean I mean what's that being as well
probably these things just don't cut it
I'm gonna I've got a technical question
has the following technical statement
been proved I know exactly how I'm going
to answer that I asked I asked my
friends I asked my peers or and if none
of them know I asked the elders I asked
the experts in my area and you know
ideally it would be nice to do that
automatically and this is one of the
many things that I think that software
might be able to do once we've made the
database I think also they can change
the way we teach I I ever so every year
now I get put in front of 270
undergraduates who've all just come out
of high school and none of them have got
a clip with the vast majority and have
got a clue what of proof is like a
rigorous logical mathematical proof they
see heuristic arguments they see you
know they told them the derivative of
sine is cosine and the the proof
involves drawing a very thin triangle
and heuristic ly arguing that that if
you have a very very thin triangle you
know a trunk with an extremely small
angle then the two
sides are approximately the same length
which is intuitively obvious but that's
not the kind of thing you can type into
the lean theorem proof you see them so
they come with a very with a very vague
idea about what a proof is and what they
can get away with and all of a sudden
they find out a university that they
can't get away with anywhere near as
much as they used to be able to get out
you know it is true that the derivative
of sine is cosine but we feel that this
needs a proof and the proof that we're
going to give them is very different to
the premium fact the proof that and the
proof I was told it's called a circular
the proof that the derivative of sine is
cosine because it involves you do the
algebra and you end up reducing to the
case of zero you need to prove that the
derivative of sine at zero is is cosine
so you have to compute sine of X divided
by X and then take the limit as X tends
to 0 and and the proof of this involves
somehow drawing the graph of sine and
saying well it looks kind of intuitively
obvious and then you say and actually
later on we'll prove after a while you
forget about the question that the
derivative of sine is cosine the
question is what's the limit as X tends
to 0 of sine X divided by X and then
once people have forgotten that that was
relevant you say well later on will
prove that the derivative of a sine is
cosine and so that means that this slope
must be 1 because the cosine of 0 is 1
and somehow circular argument is slipped
in so we get told rubbish at school and
then I have to pick up the pieces and I
got interested in lean because I thought
it was because kids like software right
it's very did 20 years ago kids didn't
use software because there wasn't
software and now there's loads of
software and kids have it kids have
computers in their pockets and I figured
great let's let's show them what proof
is using software because you know
they'll like it so that was right that's
how I started doing mean and I think
that this is this this is almost
certainly going to happen and this might
happen right I just don't know this is
this is your problem not my problem can
you actually could you actually start
making these tools to generate new
theorems or generate new proofs and I
don't know but then again I've seen
computers do things like beating he was
a chess and beating humans ago and so
you know maybe they can beat humans at
maths so I did I just I just don't know
what's possible but it would be very you
know I want to be there when it happens
and I want to understand what's going on
so I in April I met this guy called
Christians eggy at Google and he thinks
it's all gonna within 10 years he says
he has a PhD in combinatoric so he's an
expert in a certain kind of maths
I've got PhD in algebraic number theory
which is a completely different kind of
maths and I'm rather more skeptical I I
think that we when we talk about
mathematics we might be meaning
different things but he seems very
bullish and you know one of his papers
has got 15,000 citations so you've got
to take him seriously but he has a team
that's you know using up there using
Ysabel not lean using Isabelle and he's
gonna do stuff and I don't think he's a
bells good enough to do or I don't think
he's a bell it's good enough to
understand all the mathematics but it
might be good enough to understand all
of what he thinks it's mathematics so
that's the that's the situation so I'm
just gonna expand on various things so
Who am I I mean I mean algebraic number
theorists so you know ultimately we are
interested in questions about the
non-negative integers and it turns out
there are questions like Fermat's Last
Theorem which are very very simple to
state and extremely difficult to prove
this took us 350 years between the
statement and the proof is very very
innocuous looking statements so
completely no use to anyone this is you
know just it's a it's a puzzle but it's
you know it's just a great example of
something that turned out to be
extremely difficult and I'm very lucky
because while I was a PhD student my
adviser and his advisers approved it so
I was all of a sudden in the middle of
everything I've learned a whole bunch of
techniques that turn out to be suddenly
extremely fashionable because
mathematics has passion
I learnt a whole bunch of techniques and
all of a sudden they were extremely
fashionable and hello oh I've read the
proof it's fine so complicated
yeah takes an ex-player it's right
but there's laziness now this low so I
read that I read the wiles and Taylor
work so that part's fine but you know
there's 50 references I mean yeah so
I'll take so let me fast forward a
little bit how does the proof of
Fermat's Last Theorem go it breaks into
two steps firstly you proved that the
semi-stable taniyama-shimura conjecture
implies Fermat's Last Theorem and
secondly you prove the semi-stable
taniyama-shimura conjecture I'll ask the
strategy and now the big problem with
software as it stands is that even
though it's existed for 30 years to
steer improving software nobody has got
around to even stating that semi
stapleton turning our machinery
conjecture so we can't even write the
first line of the proof currently and
these things have existed for thirty
years
so the prove alas theorem is
structurally complex it involves even
though it's a statement about positive
non-negative integers the objects that
are involved in the proof are incredibly
complicated like they take pages and
pages may just to define so we've had to
invent complex structures in order to
prove a simple-looking
say but about simple structures and that
is sort of general phenomenon of
mathematics it's sort of mathematics in
number theory is just undecidable right
in general and so certain simple
questions about the natural numbers you
can solve easily and then some somehow
you have to I think this is somehow and
this is an S this is the possible nature
of mathematics there are some statements
which are easy to state but hard to
prove and then there are some times
which are easy to say to impossible to
prove
but the proof of first are serious long
you pointed out but there's that's
nothing compared to what we're doing
nowadays because people are
collaborating you know it's easy to pass
latex documents around people just write
200 page proofs sync them up on the
archive and they look very professional
because they're all written in
professionally typeset software and the
moment they're on the archive but the
people can start citing them even though
they've not been referees if you just if
you trust the authors this why would i
cite a paper on the archive that hasn't
been referees one of two reasons right
if i trust the author I'll cite it
and if if I'm desperate for if I'm
desperate for the result and this is the
only reference I know
then I'll cite it you know but yeah who
cares of anyone's checked it because the
currency you know our currency is
theorems we want new theorems so I just
decided to get nervous and and that was
another reason nervousness about the
reliability of the literature was what
was one thing that started making me
think about using theorem provers and
then being told to teach a course about
proof may be actually made it actually
happen so very briefly the background I
people told me that Haskell was kind of
I knew some Python but real hassle was
cool because it was completely different
I tried it but I didn't get it and then
I was given this course to teach and so
then I thought I should go back to house
girl because because it was something it
was more mathematical I don't know I
tried again the second time I did very
well I read this learn you at Haskell
for great good the second time I managed
to get through those hilarious and then
and then somebody asked some question
about this is a fancy theorem in
mathematics a very long is a thing with
a very long proof and it was formalized
in a rival system a system called Kok
and the proof was formalized it took
years it took years to do and I thought
oh this is kind of cool because that's a
that's a relatively respectable theorem
the odd order theorem he got John
Thompson the Fields Medal the proof is
quite low level there's this the the old
order theory was a question about finite
groups which are relatively simple
mathematical objects and the proof is
lots and lots and lots of arguments
involving finite groups so it's
different to Fermat's Last Theorem
first how serious a question about
numbers but the proof involves lots and
lots of complicated structures this this
involves lots and lots of in in G
ingenious arguments about finite groups
and it's the theorem about finite groups
so I goofed around with this and I
thought yeah this is kind of nice there
was a tactic framework and I could prove
simple like yeah the kind of things I
wanted to teach my undergraduates and
then Tom Hales gave a talk in Cambridge
in 2017 which was live streams by the
Newton Institute this is these are links
by the way if you if I distribute the
PDF afterwards you can click on these
links and Tom Hales announced that he
was going
make a gigantic mathematical database
that had all a pure mathematics in and
and he didn't mention any he didn't name
any software by name and at the end
somebody asked him what software was he
gonna use and he said he he said my
proposal is lean and I thought I've
never even heard of lean but but I trust
hails so I thought let's let's let's
forget let's learn lean so I by
this stage I'm convinced that one could
try and formalize all about I've seen
what can do and I've realized that
all the mathematics I know is just kind
of based on logic and understands
logic so I think yeah why not let's
formalize all the mathematics it sounds
like an interesting
it sounds like an interesting project
and so because Hales chose lean I think
right I'm gonna choose lean I'll give it
a try
so I tried and that I moved away
from but lean I tried and and never
moved away from because it seemed to me
to be the right tool and and now I
believe it's the only tool that's
currently available
I mean other tools will of course appear
so I stuck with lean and and now all I
want to do I don't want to do
mathematics on pen and paper anymore
because I don't trust it and I don't
trust other people that use it which is
everyone I mean he says I'm sort of
having a midlife crisis I think that's
what's really happening but you know if
like given a choice between using free
and open source software and buying a
Ferrari this is this is this is summer
this is somehow a cheaper option so so I
wanna so I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
stick to lean and now my job is because
I'm sort of one of three mathematicians
in the UK that's heard of this by a
mathematician I don't mean these people
doing category theory and type theory
you know people that say they're
mathematicians but ask proper
mathematicians regard with deep
suspicion well I say mathematician I
mean a proper mathematician someone some
of the dislike topology or analysis none
of these yeah
none of these category theory people
these these people are dying in my
country they're retiring from master
farms they're not being replaced they're
finding their way to other they're being
hired by computer science departments or
philosophy departments
but for 20 years we had no foundational
people at all at Imperial and the
foundational people that taught me in
Cambridge Peter Johnson who wrote some
book about top-off theory he wrote the
Bible of tapas theory he's retired and
he's not he's not been replaced we don't
care about these silly you know we don't
understand logic there's no point in
logic you know somebody checked that
logic worked for mathematics and so now
we can just get on with our mathematics
that's how we proper mathematician to
think about it so I'm one of you know
two or three proper mathematicians in my
country that knows about this software
and because I think it's going to turn
the entire world upside down I think
it's my job to try and to try and tell
them about it so let's start with the
undergraduates ie I love teaching both
my parents were teachers so I thought
I'll try and teach the undergraduate C
use this software that's the plan so I
just kind of curry myself in I started a
blog
yeah I'd never done anything like that
before I'm on Twitter and started an
undergraduate Club and and so it
basically said come along and we'll
figure out you know we'll figure out how
to use this software together and
because I'm very I'm a very visible
lecturer all the students know me
because I've been teaching this
first-year course for several years and
is a compulsory course so I yeah I saw I
can if I tell a bunch of students to go
and do something a lot of them will do
it so I said come to my club so like 70
people all show up for this first week
and then we realized that actually this
software's really hard to use and we
don't quite know what we're doing and
it's is a very high entry bar so lots
and lots of people came in week one and
by you know by the end of the semester
there was about sort of six people
coming and then by the beginning of next
semester there was about two people
coming and what was it so the two people
were Chris Hughes and Kenny Lau and what
was quite funny was by February they
were both better than me because you
know they're young I you know I'm 50
years old I learned think I can still
learn things but it just takes me some
time I have to be told things three
times before they sink in and I'm not
used to undergraduate spin but I'm
hot right I'm an expert puzzle solver
I'm a professor of algebraic number
theory I spent all my time dealing with
these undergraduates and they can never
tell me anything I don't know right
that's been true for 20 years
I'm absolutely I dominate the
undergraduates they they they can ask me
the hardest question they come up with
and I can answer it because they find
the material trivial and for the first
time in my life
undergraduates are telling me things
that I'm interested in so I thought this
was really interesting from a
pedagogical point of view is that I'm
actually trying to use this software I'm
getting stuck and they're telling me you
know they're telling me the way I should
be thinking about mathematics so this
was extraordinary and these two people
somehow ended up and one of them is now
one of them is now a maintainer of lenes
maths library and yeah these these
people are very smart so two years ago
neither of them knew anything about type
theory or computers or anything they
were at school and now they're writing
in a professional software they're
writing pr's they've written 30,000
lines of a you know professional level
professional code so I think that's kind
of weird so then my institution started
noticing that I was doing something a
bit strange they they have a pedagogy
transformation grant money for summer
projects and I had I've got three kids
I'd spent 20 years never doing any
summer projects because I was having two
babies at my partners of surgeon so
she's very busy so I would babysit cuz
I'm an academic I would just take the
summer off and through the childcare my
kids are all teenagers now so for the
first time last summer I thought I can
actually go to work during the summer
and just leave them at home and just
hope they don't burn the place to hell
so I so because I'd spend 20 years doing
know several projects at all I said I'll
do 20 really will you pay for them and
Imperial came up with a came up with
money to pay for 20 summer projects and
all of a sudden I had 20 undergraduates
and I said right let's just like
digitize bits of the curriculum take any
piece of master you thought was
interesting let's type it up into loon
we had a really good time and then
October 2018 the new first years coming
I'm teaching my course again and I've
got this kind of group
ten students that actually know what
they're doing so we've got 70 people in
week one and then I got like 50 people
in week two and you know the students
are talking to each other which is
perfect about mathematics so the search
took a lot longer to die down and now
there's a kind of a core group of ten
you know by the time you know when the
exams come there's then it's only the
hardcore people come so I've gone from
two hardcore people to ten hardcore
people and and you know in October it's
gonna start again
and now I've got lots and lots of people
that know what they're doing including
several people that know what they're
doing more better than me so that's
what's happening with the undergraduate
certain period College London and what
what have they actually done I we
arrived at a perfect time because Lina
just got all the prerequisites available
to start doing mathematics the way a
mathematician does pretty much not quite
but you know things like a theory of
finite sets that we think of as trivial
it was you know thousands of lines of
type theory code was there in the maths
lab we already and so I just told the
students well you just take some random
undergraduate piece of maths and
formalize because none of it this is all
undergraduate level mathematics and none
of it was that the complex numbers
weren't even in loom and I started my
first achievement in lene was defined a
complex number as a pair of real numbers
and then proved basic facts about the
complex numbers and I'm just thinking if
I can do this I can do anything because
that's exactly how I think about
mathematics so I just said you know take
around of theorem 1 you prove it some of
these students were quite hard to prove
some of it is some of these as
substantial pieces of work but they're
all done and the undergraduate city with
very little help from me really they
just kind of got the hang of it and they
talk to each other and they worked it
out
and these software's been around for
decades but as a teacher I'm interested
in yeah where's the undergraduate
mathematics degree that would be for me
a very natural thing to formalize and
it's not there in any of the systems
people just do bits and bobs they kind
of choose an area and they do that here
why can't we have one coherent body
where all of the undergraduate all of
the mathematics and the normal
undergraduate degree is there in one
library or at least in one system thirty
years this software's been around
is no one's ever done now the proof of
the odd order theorem they needed bits
and bobs from an undergraduate
curriculum you know they needed the
theurgy a group Theory course and the
third year algebraic number theory
called half of the third year algebraic
number theory
so they formalize those bits but they're
not try to make a library they were
trying to prove a theorem so they just
you know they did bit somewhere as weird
I just a different way of doing things
why don't we just digitize our
curriculum you know the students III
don't know what that will achieve it'll
be fun right it might teach the students
something I don't know it might create
an object that's never been created
before
I'm a blue sky research right now I you
know that's great I do
normal prose I say I want to prove some
theorems in the area that we're all
proving theorems in I want to prove
similar-looking new theorems i I think
this is much more exciting I'm gonna
make a new object I'm going to make an
undergraduate degree so there you go so
here's some undergraduates I really into
cotton policy and international
university Ellen is German sang-woo is
Korean Kenny's from Hong Kong he is
French Emilia's British Jones from
Taiwan Rollins Australia and Blair's
Chinese Abi's Indian Callas Swedish all
these people of have written code that's
now in Lee's maths library all these
people and every single without
exception none of them knew a damn thing
about type theory or you know coding or
anything they're all mathematic students
and I've taught them all to write
professional code and these people here
Sean and Kirkland REM um they've done
projects with me this ramones MSC
project was formalizing the definition
of a scheme which is an MSC level
mathematical object there was a no
system 30 years we've had this
fundamental vladimir Voivod tsuki got a
feel smell for proving a theorem at
schemes and then he went often invented
univ a land type theory and ten years
later had he formalized the definition
of a scheme no he hadn't and what is
going on an undergraduate an MSC student
formalized the definition of a scheme
and then then i started looking around
seeing how it was done in the other
systems and i found that it wasn't there
in the other system
this is publishable work and i so it me
is for author paper me and three
undergraduates
because I formalized it with two
undergraduates in a poor way if we made
some design poor design decisions
because we're amateurs and once I'd
learned how we should have done it I
gave it Ramon as an MSC project to fix
up you know to do what we should have
done this and I'm collaborating with
undergraduates maybe that's normal in
computer science departments that that's
absolutely unheard of in pure
mathematics because we dominate the
students they have to they have to be
doing phd's before they can even get to
the point where they're asking questions
which find interesting so this is very
strange for me and very exciting as well
as an educator so I I've written a piece
recently in the London math society news
I you know within the UK sort of a small
place and I'm a known person and I was
asked by the London math Society of had
write a piece for their newsletter about
your software and I did it's a small
five page thing but I talk more about
undergraduate stay because I figure that
you know a lot of general mathematicians
in the UK reading this will not be so
interested in my great research or
whatever but they might be interested in
teaching because that's what's paying
the bills for us so what do the
undergraduates not like they they're
smart
the only reps of my university they got
the hang of the software but they the
documentation is harder because it's
written by computer scientists for
computer scientists so somebody needs to
write documentation there's more
mathematician appropriate so I can do
that I just haven't done it yet
and the other thing is they all use
Windows laptop eclis cheap Windows
laptops and to install the software they
need to install a command line and type
things like get whatever a git clone or
something you know these really exotic
commands that mathematicians are never -
we don't use we don't use computers we
don't we don't use anything so I had to
do all you know one of the major parts
of my job over the summer was to teach
20 undergraduates how to use gears this
is because it's a really really
essential tool which is not taught is
it's not taught and to use git you kind
of I mean you know it's just sort
religious to get the easiest way to
compile lean is rather command-line you
know you just download some compiled
binaries
using some command line I don't know I
got a bit frustrated after a while and I
we use something called Co calc instead
which works really well this is
multiplayer lean my vs code has some
multiplayer option but it doesn't work
with lean do you know did you ever try
it using multiplayer loon vs code you
several people can edit a file at the
same time but the lean server is only
running on one computer is on the
running on the host computer and the
guest computer can use the server but it
can't import all the imports file
because it attempts to do the imports
locally and then there's some
compatibility issues Coco has solved all
these so I've run kind of multiplayer
kokal webinars where we go through a
file and we all edit it together
it works really well but you have to pay
and so you know and I can't pay for 270
undergraduate licenses I mean I I could
ask my department my departments already
given me you know tens of thousands of
pounds I mean they might buy it well one
thing I've learnt is that you can engage
undergraduates and even with no
programming background you can teach
them it's exhausting but you can teach
them to use this software and the other
thing that my department did was I asked
for a specialist in education to come
and examine what I'm doing because I was
giving lectures but the last year I gave
this course I gave let I would fire up
lean improve I would state theorems and
then I would prove them in lean and I
would give out notes that had the proof
your traditional PDF proofs but I would
actually I would do lively encoding in
lectures and these these people watched
what I was doing
interviewed 40 of the undergraduates did
surveys and they're currently writing an
education paper about my intervention as
it's called but it's not ready yet it's
coming up beginning of October
apparently they've been very
tight-lipped about what they're going to
say I don't really know you know they
might just say this guy's an idiot right
but who knows but you know it'll be
interesting to see what happens
so my call starts again in October and
now I know what I'm doing so all the
notes will be formalized all the problem
sheets will be formalized and they will
simply have a choice you can do it in
the old-fashioned way with pen and paper
or you can do it on a computer and and
the course has been reorganized other
people are teaching parts of it and I
took precisely the parts which sort of
the maximally easiest and funnest to do
in lean and we're gonna do those first
so the first eight lectures that the new
undergraduates of my university the new
math undergraduate don't see what will
all be given by me they just go to one
course and it's my course and it's going
to be heavily heavily lean related and
we'll just see right we'll just see and
that the cut that what the notes will
look like is a guy called Patrick naso
in all say he's where are we going it's
there somewhere oh here it is
he's um he's already done this he this
is a this is his he gave an introduction
to prove course as well you know there's
some there's some basic stuff about
equivalence relations but down here
here's a here's a proof and you can
you can fold everything up and then just
looks like a normal mathematical proof
but then you can unfold things and you
can see the state you can see the
tactics state before and after so
there's before and there's after that
next slide and there's after that next
line and what I've learned very quickly
is that mathematicians find this
extremely hard to follow because these
are lean tactics you know this is you
know it's language specific things like
this quotient exists rep that students
find this hard to follow but students
within a couple of lectures within a
couple of hours of my course students
can understand what this what's going on
here because this is just normal math is
absolutely is all done in Unicode which
is crucial
really students understand what this
says with with very little training and
even if they can't follow this stuff you
can just click through keep clicking on
these great things here and they can
watch the tactic state change and they
can follow it and they can see what's
happening and they began begin to learn
what a proof is so that's what
the reasons I got interested in lanes
sort of literally prove it
this is Patrick Maseo wrote some Python
code which takes a lien file with
comments but the comments are it's an
inlay tank yes so this is the source
code for this is a lien file which
compiles and runs with comments written
in latex and he runs it through some
Python code and it produces a webpage
that looks like this so that problem is
solved and so that's great for me
because I just need to type up my eight
lectures in lean put comments and latex
which I can just knock off absolute you
know but very quickly and then you
compile it and then I have this and
that's what I'm gonna be showing the
students and it won't be in French so so
there we go so there's the
undergraduates and as I say I I'm
convinced that it it shows them a new
way of thing it turns proving into a
game right it turns proving into a game
that's that's what it is
and games are great right kids if you if
you watch the students when they finish
doing maths they play games they play
games on their phone they play games on
their PC
you know they play nerdy games they play
minecraft they play all sorts of things
but that's that's what I think this
that's how I sell this software right
it's something I need to teach I'm
turning it into a game so it's more fun
and then as well as that I want to
digitize the curriculum so in three
years time when we're finished cuz you
know it's ticking along we have to say
Imperial College you know all theorems
formally verified in Lane very a cool
thing so okay this is just some this is
the first this is me two years ago first
question on the first example sheet is
it true that if X is a real number in x
squared minus three X plus two is zero
then X is one the question has an
implication sign in x squared minus 2 X
plus 2 equals zero implies x equals one
so I've failed to typeset the main point
of the question there should be an
implication sign because I'm trying to
teach them what that symbol means X
implies Y so what I expect the students
to say is no this is not
because X can be 2 so you type that into
lean you if you're me two years ago
learning yourself you say x equals two
and then lean says great so now now
you've reduced the question to proven
the two squared minus three times two
plus two is there and now you've got to
prove that two isn't one so so as a
student is a student how you're gonna
prove that two equals this is impossible
right because this is a quotable fact so
then you can initially I was thinking
this is a floor with my plan because now
the students are going to say this
software is stupid because how does it
not know that two isn't one but now I've
turned that around I said to this use
well how do you know that to isn't one
is that an axiom like 53 isn't
twenty-eight is that an axiom is that a
rule is that a theorem what's actually
going on here
I thought this initiative is just being
annoying but now I've realized that
actually there's that there's a there's
a pedagogical point to this now I'm
showing the students that the things
they thought were obvious about the real
numbers we need to find a way of
justifying it and there's a tactic that
solves these now when I ran into this
issue I couldn't I couldn't do anything
I mean I was stuck and I asked on the
lean chat and they're like oh yeah
that's quite hard because the real
numbers are really complications these
are integers it'd be fine but
unfortunate I've asked question about
real numbers last year I changed the
question to an X an integer but this
year I changed it back again to let's be
real number because now we have two
tools to do this you know there's
there's tactics that resolve questions
like this so I raised this on the lip I
said undergraduates can't use your
software list unless this could be made
easy
mathematics under pressures can't use it
as that was made easy so right so
students went really well and I love
students and that was really great so
now what about the star so initially
they would just I kind of Kevin's doing
a stupid thing Kevin's doing something
we don't understand but I started
telling people about it's like you know
this was going to change the world and
you know we should all learn it and it's
very important and again and again and
again I get this question can it
actually tell us anything new because
that's what we're interested in we're
not interested in the old order thing
that's old we're interested in new
theorems so where are the new theorems
that this software is generating
and my answer to this always used to be
no and I've realized that that's not a
very good answer it doesn't sell it very
well so I've changed my answer and now I
say not yet which is also valid it's
equally true it's a lot more positive
and it more accurately flex my beliefs
not yet but on what it's still enough to
make 90% of people stop listening
instantly because that's what
mathematicians want they want new
theorems that's that's that's what
excites us so there we go there's this
other system called it's sort of
it's an old version of it's the same
type theory as lean but you know with
more you know with more design errors
lean I guess learned a lot from so
there's this proof of the four-color
theorem which is this famous theorem
because it it was the proof was weird
because it was like thousands of special
cases and mathematicians were
uncomfortable about it then there's this
old order theorem that's also checked in
Cocke the proof of this is low-level
there's hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of theorems about finite groups
put together in a clever way so this has
been formalized in Cocke and the
conclusions release is that is that the
software can handle theorems which take
hundreds of pages these things are
hundreds of pages of long hundreds of
pages long and the software can handle
it and compile it yeah in an hour or two
the software is ready to handle proofs
which are hundreds of pages long that's
an important data point this work is
phenomenally important because it means
that the whole thing is feasible and as
I say these have been formalized in some
older software but if can do it
then lien can do it
I don't I don't know anything I don't I
don't have anything that can do
that lien can't in theory do as well but
why why aren't people interested on one
reason is because we don't care about
the odd order theorem because it was
proof fifty years ago and and ten years
after that they proved this
classification theorem for finite simple
groups which answered the big unsolved
question about finite simple finite
groups and then everyone left the area
and the area became doubt so the area's
been dead since the 1980s and then in
2012 all these computer scientists like
oh we've formally verified the odd order
theorem well like you know there's
nobody
left who's interested in more so just
they've just got you know they've
retired and gone that the area is dead
we care about fashionable mathematics
and finite groups are no longer
fashionable you know in some sense this
was a very poor choice but in another
sense it taught us a lot of things but
for Vermont I'm interested in marketing
right I'm interested in marketing your
software to my people and this is a poor
this is a poor choice and the other
thing it's course is that we're also
sufficiently arrogant we know what a
proof is and approved as if the elders
say it's okay right and do the elders
think that this proof of your daughter
theorem is okay yes they do think it's
okay they gave Thompson a Fields Medal
right and that's it the committee of
elders gave him the Fields Medal and so
we're there right that that that means
that the proof is except who cares if
it's correct the question is is it
accepted that's what we want to know and
this theorem is accepted so we don't
care if it's correct because it's
because because it's good enough right
and it's pretty sure it's correct we all
knew it was correct because everything
that's accepted is correct apart from
the small number of errors that we've
made right and we don't know where the
errors are but history says that the
errors that the number of errors you
made is extremely small because we're
good
we mathematicians we're good at react we
we're good at smelling problems you know
something if it's some argument doesn't
quite look right or looks incomplete or
your gut feeling is that what's known
isn't going to be enough to prove that
result then you can smell it and if you
if you smell a bad smell then you've got
this 200 page paper you don't read it
from the beginning you start looking at
the statements of the lemmas and you
know I believe that I believe that I
believe that all this looks optimistic
and you read that lemma very very
carefully and if and it's a and if the
proof is fine you've learned something
the proof isn't fine you reject the
paper so we're very good at reading
gigantic papers an extremely nonlinear
way and and trying to work out what's
right or not so we knew this was right
because this was read by hundreds of
people and you know I think I think
there might be some problems but I don't
think it's all wrong and I think that
the chances are something big that we
believe turns out to be wrong I think
there's actually quite small
so I don't think that's the way of
selling their software to mathematicians
so Fermat's Last Theorem the statement
is trivial but what does the proof look
like first we spend 300 years fiddling
around inventing algebraic number theory
basic algebraic number theory and that
gets us to the early 1900s there by the
1930s we invent elliptic curves and
modular forms and then we've been ten
other things this is the 60 seventies
and eighties and then we start these are
the each definition relies on earlier
definitions and so by the end of it some
of these definitions are huge and then
we put all of these things together so
three hundred and fifty years so far we
put all these things together and we get
it but now that here's the problem is
that I can't get my undergraduates to do
this bit because this is this is what
you learn when you're doing a PhD I
can't get them to formalize the
definition of a P attic our presentation
because they don't know what it is and
my experience is that you shouldn't try
and teach somebody some new interesting
and complicated mathematics while
simultaneously get them to formalize it
that's the thing you should get them to
formalize stuff that they understand
that that's that's what works best
first they understand it then they
formalize it and then they really
understand it and it stays forever so
this is just too much I could spend a
year supervising them an MSc student to
learn what these objects are but then
we've got no time for the formalizing
you see so the proof goes like this you
invent all these complex structures you
prove some relationships between them
and then the theorem just comes out in
the wash that's how it that's how it
works that's what mathematics looks like
you invent a bunch of you invent
sufficiently complex tools and then you
let the tools do all the heavy lifting
for you so the proof of course takes
thousands of pages and no one's really
read it so then it could be formalized
let's listen there's a project while I
formula I know I know the proof or I
know bits of it I know the wilds tale
apart I don't know what the proofs of
all the references
well I formalized the proof I could lead
that team I've led teams before I built
up number theory from nothing in London
I could build up this stuff here but it
will cost a huge amount of money
and it will cost a huge amount of money
and the problem is we don't care because
the elders have said it's fine
right the elders have said the proof is
fine so what's the point in checking it
so there's one obstruction to doing it
is that no mathematician sees so no no
agency the funds mathematics or funder
either because how does it work I send
my proposal off and then they send it to
mathematician to the master which we
should look what's the point of this
it's an absurd amount of money to do
something that there's no point so
that's not the way to tell it either
okay we don't care because the elders
say it's fine we know it's fine because
we gave while surprise and it's
interesting because no human actually
understands it mathematics is quite
modular this is the sort of side remark
no no mathematician understands the
proof of Fermat's theorem the full proof
I mean many of them have read was its
paper or the references but I there's
some I've never read the proof of the
Langlands tunnelled theorem because it's
just a lot of harmonic analysis but I
understand the statement and I can
insert the statement you know I can I
can apply the st. Montano the proof
because I don't know enough analysis are
in algebra so the proof is modular and
different people that we trust in the
community of verify different pieces of
it and so now he says it's fine and it's
getting worse as I say nowadays nowadays
people are verifying proofs where you
know if an elder says and this is
forthcoming work but I'm putting it on
the archive now that I know two
instances just in the last couple of
years where people have brazenly said
there is a hundred missing pages
literally a hundred I've asked authors
you say this is forthcoming work how
long do you think that work will be and
when is it going to appear and I've had
a hundred pages just missing stuff and
if we don't is fine right it's the way
the system works it's the way the system
works and it's it's difficult to disrupt
that I say look at that is this really
fine are we actually doing mathematics
and the answer is yes of course we are
that's how it's always worked it's fine
they will appear but in 10 years time
those hundred pages will probably have
been written by some poor PhD student or
postdoc you know it's a tedious
technical result that everybody knows
all the experts say the techniques are
there what's even the point of writing
it will get a PhD student to write it
will teach them the area
yes an efficient way of going about it
so it's sort of funny and I'm beginning
and deep trust a PhD student I don't
know I I because I'm getting a bit
paranoid I'm yeah I'm sort of not is
that's not the way to sell that's not
the way to sell the software so we
accepted the proof in 1970 we gave John
Thomson Fields Medal and that's why we
know the order of ministry we don't care
that it was formally checked in code we
don't even understand what that means
99% of the people I work with don't even
understand what that means we formally
verified the proof because they don't
know set theory they don't know what you
know they just do mathematics the way
Gauss and Euler did that gas that all he
didn't have axioms and foundations they
were still doing mathematics we're doing
it like that still you know the set
theories check that there's some way of
making it work with foundations but we
don't care so they don't really know
what the thing means so well are we
interested in we're interested in
perfect toyed spaces that's what we're
interested in which are fancy new
objects which we've made about five
years ago so here's the table there's
the proof of the odd order theorem
that's what you guys thought was going
to be exciting that's the thing that
really is exciting they both got fields
medals but where have they gone right no
one in my department there's only about
the old order theorem because there's no
one doing finite group here anymore but
my PhD students all know what the vector
spaces and so do the PhD students the
person in the office next to me perfecto
spaces are exciting right I got a
formalised to scheme that was 50
year-old mathematics I was like this is
great this is MSC level mathematics that
if their improver and I talk to
algebraic geometers know like I learned
what a scheme was when I was an MSC
student and I realized I had to go
higher so perfected spaces are vastly
complicated mathematical structures and
we did it I thought let's learn let's
really learn that this is what taught me
how to use the software in a serious way
me and a topologist and a postdoc in
number theory all of whom I met online
in the lien theorem proved achat all of
us uh mathematicians
it took us eight months we formalized
the definition of effective space it's
like ten thousand lines of code and they
loved it
mathematicians love it they don't
understand it but they know it's
different so I get invited to give
colloquia all all around
the place it's absolutely great up and
out hi I built a whole but about the
stuff that we formalized and that's what
took us eight months so it so it goes
all the way down to it goes all the way
down to the axioms oh all goes all the
way down to leans mat slightly when meat
leans Matt's life okay so he's
compulsive sorry for it and yeah we had
to formalize a whole bunch of general
boreback ease general topology you know
a very formal math textbook the
topologist did that and then we did the
graduate level number theory on top me
and the number theorist
this guy here is a postdoc he's putting
his job on the line here right this will
not this work who referees this somebody
who understands type theory and perfecto
spaces who's that that's that's me
that's me that's me and this guy I only
I don't think I'm a valid referee we've
written some weird paper that just falls
between the cracks because it's tyke
theories are big right calm theoretical
computer science is a big area algebraic
number theory is a big area number of
people in both is tiny so it sort of
find we don't quite know what to do with
it we're writing the paper and we'll see
we'll write it the paper we'll stick it
in the system
and we might just completely fail to
obviously but I don't care you know if
the computer scientists don't see the
word I'm not targeting the computer
scientist you kind of get it at least
you understand what the software is
doing I'm this is a PR exercise for me I
need to get more mathematicians involved
because I have a vision I have a
gigantic vision and I'm one person
perfect all its phases took eight months
you know how many definitions there are
there's hundreds there's thousands of
definitions right this is this is both
right I specifically chose four factoids
spaces because I knew that
mathematicians found it's sexy and and I
was right I've formalized some a vector
space and I've done some stuff with
undergraduates I'm you know great
there's give the colloquium and give me
the colloquium in Durham in two weeks
time and in Exeter I mean I'm going
length and breadth of the country and in
the EU as well I give them talk in
Germany about it all it's great and I'm
just you know I'm just basically being
an evangelist for your software it
doesn't tell us anything right it's
again it's the first question does it
tell us any new theorems I'll tell you
what it does
to state old theorems we can state the
theorems shunts have proved a theorem
about perfect or spaces and got a Fields
Medal now we can state that theorem but
you can't prove it hey can we prove a
new theorem we don't if you can't state
it where do you begin right now we can
state it that's where you have to start
that's why I'm doing it because you have
to start somewhere and it's sort of
ridiculous and computer scientists say
you've made a definition that's like
it's like I'm making a class I'm at you
know lean enables you to reason about
code and you can prove a hard theorem
you can prove that this code does a
certain complicated thing you can prove
a hard theorem and that's a triumph I'm
just defining a class like anyone can do
that maybe I've made a mistake sure but
I mean you know maybe maybe the
definitions not right and if the
definitions changed since it was married
it was it was tinkered with and if it
gets tinkered with again that's fine
I'll just take it with my code I don't
care whether it's right or not I'm you
know we have something so this is yeah I
mean let's skip this bit cuz I want to
stop on time
the formalizing definitions is difficult
so in hello you still probably won't
trust yeah I trust software more than I
trust mathematicians that it's as simple
as that
because I I found mistakes this is this
is what's really going on
I referee papers and once I had a really
bad experience referring a paper I spent
two years arguing with the authors that
their proof was incomplete and
eventually I won but I was the referee
and this took a lot out of me I'd young
children at the time and it basically
destroyed my and that the authors were
experts and it destroyed my trust in
humans and I might trust in leo software
has not yet been destroyed by any
means.the it's I I think there's the
orders of magnitude and it is automatic
it's an order packaging more reliable I
don't care that it might not you know I
don't care that it's not a hundred
percent
lene doesn't have an ego so why do I
want them to use it because I've got a
plan right
i I we need to before we can start
proving new theorems we need to be able
to state old theorems and that's what we
can't do because we can't state the
semi-stable turning our machinery
conjecture because we haven't even
defined the definitions so there's all
the definition there's not millions
there's only hundreds of thousands right
there's not that many I've done one it
took me 8 months I'm getting better at
it now though won't take me eight months
to do the next one I've just written an
e new grant proposal where I broke
proposed to do ten more right but what
you would love to do really is just feed
in the book just take the book apart you
know feeding the PDF let the computer
read it and and then interpret the
natural language and then that's great
and it's just that's a million miles
away I think I'm not an expert in this
but my impression is that computers
cannot read human generated mathematics
I think you actually have to write it
properly and so to do to get
mathematicians to do that you have to
teach mathematicians to write in this
programming language
it's no good teaching them to write in
English you have to and that's what I'm
doing and I can't really get this after
to it yeah so that's why I'm getting the
students to do it but you have to there
has to be a new culture we have to start
making students write in this if they
want they should be able to write in
this language because I've got a
thousand definitions I want to do its
maths and computer science like grant
agencies should love this because it's
got its synergy right but let's find out
let's see if it actually I mean there's
problems so as I say this husband for 30
years
but if you ask a random mathematician in
my department they're working on they'll
they'll state a theorem and it will be
put impossible to state that theorem and
any of them in any of these theorem
provers because it will be about objects
that computer scientists don't
understand it's as simple as that
because computer scientists are not
research level mathematicians right we
we're you know we're learning about
p-adic Banach spaces and we're proving
lemmas about p-adic Banach spaces
there's no definition of a purely Banach
space so the software is been around for
is and it still can't understand the
statements of what we're doing that's
how far we are away it's just it's
farcical
this is farcical 30 years it's time we
got together it's time we got together
so we don't we don't see the objects
that we think are sexy so I just written
an EU grant proposal two million two
million euros to just give me a couple
of postdocs who can just spend their
time formalizing definitions and
formalizing famous mathematical
conjectures and famous mathematical
theorems and this has gone to the EU and
on the 31st of October the UK is going
to crash out of the EU with no deal and
my grant application will instantly
become invalid because because if we
came out with a deal we would be some
kind of member whoever be some if we
come out with no deal then that's then
my grandpa Moses failed so but the idea
is like Trump lobs Johnson and the idea
is that we're going to be present
American at all so so yeah when we get
like remember me on Halloween because
because apparently America are our
friends so if you want to give me two
million dollars or even what half a
million dollars just to fund a post-doc
Microsoft funded postdoc who's just
quietly going to come and work with me
in imperial and just change the world
that would be great that would be great
right and Tom Hale says we should make a
database and Tom house is a very smart
mathematician we should just make a date
of it that's where that's where to stop
let's just make a database of
mathematical objects and then let's
state the theorems that relate these
objects to each other right that's I
think that's that's that that's the next
thing you want to do right
lene lene is the right tool currently
lean is the only viable tool currently
to do this let's tell it what modern
pure mathematics is right let's not
prove any more big theorems at 50 years
old let's just define some modern stuff
right and now who's going to do that
people like me that know the mathematics
and people that I'm making people that
I'm training I'm a professional trainer
I've graduated 15 PhD students and I've
taught 15 undergraduates how to write
math lib ready
right I can train these people but and
when we've done that you know it'll
happen somehow and when we've done that
we can make a database of stuff and a
database of links between that stuff
this implies this or you know everything
every X with property Y is you know
gives us something with properties that
you can just we can just state the
things that the elders believe you know
I don't care about proving them that's
that's you know that's harder we can
just state it and then we've made a big
database of what of our beliefs we're
writing down our belief system and that
database doesn't exist anywhere this is
a completely new kind of database and
then what we can do we can start
attaching things to the labels saying
this was proved by this person in this
journal and then suddenly we can start
searching it right because you guys can
do that kind of stuff and then you know
we can start asking basic questions I
don't know what we can do that that
seems trivial and that will be great
that will make mathematicians in the
third world you know that don't have I
have access to the elders some of them
work in the same building as me but
people that donate access to the elders
they can you they can use they can use
the database maybe we can make tools you
know undergraduates if I can persuade
the undergraduates to all work in this
software that I have to mark their work
instant feedback that's what they want
270 students and me I find it very very
difficult to give them feedback this is
one of the big biggest criticisms of my
university not enough staff too many
student we love the students because
they're paying our salaries too many
students and they want feedback right
they mutt they do some levers they write
some PDF stuff they write some stuff on
paper it goes into the machine a week
and a half later it comes back with some
PhD student who's attempted to market
not always accurately you know and
they're paying nine thousand pounds a
year for that and this gives them
instant feedback I think that's you know
I think that's that's worth something
and then of course you know world
domination right and then I give up
that's it thank you
[Applause]
the features of lien that made it well
suited for this compared to the other
systems you travel so I looked at three
I looked at four kinds of foundational
things there set theory which is what
all mathematicians if they learn
anything at all they learn set theory
but the only software doing that or
automation is very difficult with set
theory and I need automation so I gave
up on the set theory wonders their
simple type Theory Isabel you know and
the other big player really in my mind
it's you know and Isabel simple type
theory is too simple it's really great
for doing 100 year old analysis and its
really great for proving theorems about
spheres than things but you can't I mean
you can it would be extremely painful to
define a perfect toyed space in Isabel
because the fundamental object is a is a
is a dependent type is it there's a
table there's a there's a sheaf of rings
on a topological space so I need it I've
got a topological space a for every open
subset I've got a ring and this is a
dependent type and you do it in this but
you do it in a simple type Theory you
need a func you need a proper function
you can't have a dependent type you need
a function so you take the disjoint unit
of all your rings and now you've got an
object which isn't really a sensible
mathematical structure and then you put
ring structures on subtypes of it and
now all of a sudden you can't use any of
the type class in machinery because it's
not actually a ring it's a it's a
disjoint it's a big collection of rings
so you lose all you lose the type class
system so I don't want to do that I mean
it's fast it's faster than lean because
it's simple but I and it's good for some
of mathematics but I definitely want to
do all of it so and so then there's you
know valence in availab type theory and
I'll buy that I think in quite a
univariant way that looks sort of good
but they've been around volleyball
skinnies chums are around for 15 years
and you look at what they've done and
they've done nothing they've
find a ring and a module they've I don't
see any map if its second than fifteen
years and they've done nothing that I'm
very skeptical fifteen years in court
they were really doing stuff but liens
maths library when I arrived in 2017 the
software's there only a couple of years
old really in its modern form members
lean 3 released 2016 so within one year
the amount of stuff in liens maths
library just completely dominated what
I've been done in 15 years in univille
and I don't know what's wrong with you
navale at mathematics and I of course I
hope that it will work right there's a
there's something else just happened
what was it called errand some was
someone's made a new system I would love
to see you know violence work because
universe is really useful we have to
work around the fact that we don't have
you know violence but we can do it
because the system is powerful enough to
work around it that was one of the
mistakes I made in formalizing schemes
is that I just assumed that you know
violence was obvious because I'm a
mathematician I wanted to rewrite IX was
isomorphic to Y and I'd proved it theory
about X I wanted to juice the theory
about why and then I was told that life
wasn't so easy independent type theory
and that's why I started again that's
fine I've written this I'd written this
formalization of a scheme with 200
graduates and I realized that we've made
some yeah we had to work around we had
to do a lot of diagram chasing and then
I gave it to another undergraduate said
this is the mistake we've made do it in
a bit more of a universal property you
kind of way and they did it any work
fine so it's just all I've lots of
evidence that lien is good enough
perfect toward space so symbol type
theories two simple univariate type
theory it might work but someone has to
do it and I'm not I'm not I'm gonna do
finite sets finite sets of trivial but
in lean they'd all been done for me by
the people that came before me I want to
do proper mathematics so you know
univariate system seems ready and I
think that's it I can't think of any
more I need dependent types and I need a
sufficiently advanced system it's just
not as good as lean court doesn't have
quotients a perfect toyed space is a
motion with the dependent type on it
that's that's the that's the answer to
your question
a perfect toy space is a quotient with
the dependent type on it and that hence
immediately rules out and Ysabel
because doesn't do you can't really
do quote you can't make the quotient you
can have a big space with a relation on
it but you can't make the quotient type
you just have to work with the big space
in the occurrence relation you're
constantly jumping you're in something
called set oh hell that's what it's
informally known as so yeah I don't know
and it's just lean is just sexier it has
Unicode I want this it's a ridiculous
thing but for mathematicians it matters
right I'm coming from a different world
where I'm trying to sell stuff and it
just matters that we have unit Unicode
is what we write it we write upside down
A's on our bits of paper in our PDFs and
it's just that and that's what I see on
the screen hello I didn't I was told
that actor wasn't really for
mathematicians I was told it was more of
an experiment in type theory I and is
that there's no tactic framework is that
right is it just all terms to something
like as well the underlying type theory
is similar right it's close to me but
they have they have they have more
exotic types you have these inductive
recursive types or induction and I see
people talking about these things on the
lean shirts and you kind of think all
those they sound interesting higher
inductive types or whatever but actually
what I realized when I formalize
perfected spaces was that we don't need
any of that stuff mathematicians just
want structures you know that I talking
to Sebastian it's quite interesting I
said you know what we never use
induction he was like oh of course you
use the natural numbers I'm just
thinking I don't think we do use the
natural numbers not on the definition of
a perfect or it so we don't need natural
there's no numbers involved there's a
prime number at some point later on in
the theory but we're dealing with
complicated objects
typically infinite-dimensional there's
no numbers involved at all in our number
theory that's what number theories
become so sort of funny so I don't I
don't need what I do has to offer
hello so I really differ a few years ago
about some proofs up for precluding
geometry yeah and one of the things that
they found was when they when they went
and took all of the rigorous proofs
using concrete actions that were
designed to hit all the geometric
intuition side of Euclid they found that
in fact they had suddenly carried over a
lot of intuition about a bunch of holes
yeah I'm curious with your students
doing number theory did they find a lot
of just medicals and the proofs that
appear Thanks
yeah they find admissions but an
omission is funding right that's that's
the difficulty on your PhD sure you're
reading a paper you don't understand it
it's just because they left a gap that
you can't Traverse yourself but you
asked the ex you know you asked your PhD
advisor and they just say well you just
do this this and this you just do the
standard technique and so and that's
interesting because you very early on it
gets drilled into your head that if you
don't understand something it's probably
your fault and it was only once I've
been in the game for about 10 15 years
that I realized that actually if I don't
understand something
it might be because it's wrong it might
be because the people that are writing
the paper might not actually understand
the subjects as well as I do but that's
not the philosophy yeah so mistakes
normal they're part of you know oh I got
one of my summer students formalized all
of that Euclidean and stuff formula
hunter at hundreds of lives of lean code
formalizing Euclid's I mean yeah
Hilbert's axioms they proved a whole
bunch of stuff it was amazing
there's one of the things one of the
many things we learned all unpublished
all on some private github repository
completely unavailable
yeah it's one of the many things yeah
yeah sure there's mistakes but we've
been out of it the undergraduate level
we know to fix them right at the
research level some of them really are
mistakes that's normal you get away with
it that's the point you get away with it
so it doesn't doctor
hello so kind of believes my earlier
question one thing I've been thinking
about is you've been talking and talking
about the different systems hmm and then
as well as how the proof development and
the English or French or any other
language pros would pair with that and
be communicated in some sense the thing
you might want to share wouldn't be you
say a lien proof development their
cognitive development but what is
generated from that and ideally have
checked by many different systems not
every time one custom edition do you
care that a particular proof development
if you sat down and read it maybe step
through it line by line the prover
actually carried any kind of human level
of semantic content or even one that
alongside some documentation and those
things can also drift sometimes saying
regular programming so what do you think
about that in terms of the future
freezing crew being so I've talked to a
lot of people a lot of mathematicians
about what a proof is and what they want
from a proof and I'm a formalist so as
far as I'm concerned if some computer
came up and generated a 1 billion line
long proof of the Riemann hypothesis in
some type theory that could be formally
checked to be correct but gave us no
understanding at all I'd be super
excited about that but I know a whole
bunch of people that would be super
super cross or might even reject it so
within the community there's huge
diversity of opinions mister as to
whether we care about semantic content
improve actually talking to Leo and
Daniel this week I did realize that I'm
very selective about which proofs I read
I tend to only read proofs if I think
theirs if I want to know what the idea
is because that all 99% of what's
published is mathematicians just
generalizing ideas that they've learnt
in other places and applying them in
that either different situations or
slightly more general situations so you
have to learn some proofs but I don't
know we've got
I'm torn the formulas part of me says I
don't care right I just think that can
be why don't we just make computers do
it all then we don't have to work no
human on says how their phone works
right almost human so on set of their
phone works so they really need to
understand our math works and then on
other days I kind of think well actually
that's the point I don't there's loads
of different answers to your question
I personally am a formalist but I know
people that would actively be cross if
you suggested that we should start
taking proofs away from them because for
them the beauty is the idea and the idea
can get lost
but beauty is one thing and truth is
another thing and I'm kind of more
worried about truth that's why I'm here
and I've met mathematicians that say
that you shouldn't believe any of their
papers their papers are just telling
stories and you know you should enjoy
the beauty of the story and they don't
really care if it's right I mean they
know they've got they've got it passed
the system so they can put it on their
CV but you know if somebody told him at
Birth earring was wrong they wouldn't be
too bothered is it extraordinary the
people when you actually start asking
delicate questions some people just
aren't yeah they claim that they don't
really even care if they're right or
wrong that's just you know the fun is
the ideas and that's what we're doing
we're just passing around abstract ideas
yeah because abstract maths is beautiful
right a perfect Tory space is a really
beautiful thing if you're one of the
very small number of people that can
understand they're so funny yeah I don't
know
oh yeah I reject beauty I want rigor but
not all of us is that an answer
hello I tried sending this to your
scientists I thought that was you going
yeah I've spoken it so I'm speaking at
something called ITP next week yeah in
Portland Oregon and I think that would
be full of theoretical computer
scientists so yeah I do talk to them
sometimes but I mostly talked to
mathematicians yeah what should I tell
them are you a theoretical computer yeah
what do they want to hear they'll love
this okay because the mathematicians are
skeptical but yeah I'm sort of I don't
know where I am I'm between the cracks
now I just I want to just make lots and
lots of noise until somebody eventually
realizes that what I'm doing is
important if it turns out to be
important but am I crazy
surely this surely this stuff will have
an impact in my area isn't that odd it's
so obvious to me it must inevitably have
an impact in my area right it is why
that's that's the selling point I just
need to convince people but I the
computer sir I mind precious that
theoretical computer scientists are kind
of taking it as far as they want you
know they have a good day it's great you
know they've done the old order theorem
they've they've done loads of stuff but
now someone else has to have a go that's
my impression I think they know that
their software is growing they don't
they're interesting to talk to him they
ask me weird questions they start asking
me about like how I come up with ideas
and things I mean quite I spent 20 years
talking to number theorists we talk
about technical number theory now all of
a sudden I've talked to people they're
asking me really weird questions about
the you know the process I go through
when I'm doing mathematics so it's
really interesting or talking to a young
group of intelligent people
you
[Applause]